so organizing for action which is
President Obama's super PAC they sent
out an email this week telling people
that they should talk about Obamacare at
the Thanksgiving table because there's
nothing better than talking politics and
policy during thanksgiving and not only
did they send an email but there was a
link to a website which would guide you
because you're the voice of reason
that's what they told you you're the
voice of reason in your family and they
give you a little guide to how you
should go about doing it so they give
you some conversation tips you can start
by asking have you thought about signing
up for health insurance on the new
marketplace grandma offer to walk them
through it would you like to take some
time with me to sign up right now ask
them to make a plan and commit to it
when do you plan on signing up don't
forget to follow up have you signed up
yet and some things that are important
to communicate being covered helps you
stay healthy and protects you in an
emergency you can find a plan that fits
your budget financial assistance is
available for all those who qualify and
you get to choose the plan that's right
for you period they should have put a
period in there okay just easy question
to start is there anything worse than
talking politics with your family at
thanksgiving look I think it's it really
unfortunately is telling of just how
much of a struggle they're having with
messaging so now they're having to send
this thing out for like a holiday
special really like come on it's not not
a good look yeah I do plan on talking
about a care at the Thanksgiving table I
probably would but my first question
would be are you willing to pay higher
premiums for the same coverage I mean
that's not on that children let's let's
be clear I actually think this is a
great idea I think this is the exact
reason why the Obama re-election team
did so well and why he was re-elected
they're very creative why not put
forward some talking points to encourage
people they've got a lot of people who
are sheep they got a lot of people who
just follow the directions and start
these conversations at the dinner table
the fact is people don't know about this
process because the website is crappy
and the messaging is terrible but I
think this is a very creative way lame
but creative yeah well alright well
speaking of lame let's take a look there
was also a video that they created and
it's like
two minute long video they think it's
really hilarious but it's actually quite
lame this is just the end of it so what
did you want to talk to me about we know
you don't have health insurance we love
you no matter what but it's time to get
covered that's it health insurance it's
important I know and I'll do it I just
thought never mind yeah something very
pandering and isn't there something sort
of insulting about that I key that's
what I'm saying to me it's insulting but
I i do get Rick's point in that this is
what they do and this is what they do
well yeah I will say I'm surprised to
see it being the parents initiating the
top with the Sun because we all know
Obama's strong point tends to be the
youth right and so I would have almost
expected the kid to bring it up to kind
of spread the message amongst the elder
generation remember this is the group
that gave us binders full of women I
mean we're talking really lame messaging
that doesn't make sense but again it
works I mean I think this war on women
thing is crap but it works and people
just hear that basic stuff it's catchy
and this is the same thing yeah so just
to the bigger idea of Obamacare at this
point I mean this obviously shows some
level of desperation that they have to
give out such specific messaging and all
that kind of stuff and also get involved
in holidays you're supposed to be
thankful I feel like it's the one day
where I try not to talk about politics
do you think this thing's going to turn
around by the by the end of the year
because i'm still looking like a
disaster no and I was so frustrated guys
to see him put another deadline for
himself when clearly that's not
something that you guys are doing well
I'm meeting the deadline so that was
look I don't know whose idea that was
what that person needs to be fired but
yeah no I don't think it's going to turn
around any time before the end of the
year so speaking of getting fired one of
every story that we've done on this on
this show I keep saying someone has to
get fine yes fire somebody someone an IT
guy the guy who is testifying that we
are we eighty percent of it wasn't even
made I spire somebody the janitor how
come no one ever gets fired well look we
r 5 years into the Obama administration
and there have been a lot of things that
have gone wrong but we just don't fire
people in government that's the Union
way you
fire people you just reassign them and I
think it's terrible i think in the
private sector you are gone immediately
and then they you know announce that
you're gonna spend more time with your
family so the simple fact is that if
they did this I think then they would
have better people coming in because
people would be feared it would be
fearful that they're gonna get fired
agree that even as somebody who tends to
lean left I agree with you a hundred
percent like I think that's the problem
with government and that's upon a lot of
people feel about it there's no
consequences when you mess up and you
when people don't have an incentive such
as keeping your job for doing it well
why are you doing it well so yeah it's
the no-brainer to me so it's part of
things they don't fire them because if
you fired one person you'd have to fire
a ton of people like it would sort of
like it's like the string that would
unleash the whole really also I i was in
government for a long time and i had a
team of 11 people that worked for me and
there was one individual who was not
doing her job having alcohol problems
sleeping at her desk and i set out with
HR to try to figure out okay how do we
gotta get rid of this person they're
clearly not working and i was told
absolutely you cannot get rid of them
you have to deal with them send them to
counseling talk to them we're not
getting rid of them you have to deal and
so as a boss you just reassign them yeah
i can't get one of those jobs but nobody
can drink during the day nobody wins and
even like somebody like you know the
teachers unions and stuff and I love
teachers I went to public school they're
amazing but I had classes where I'm like
is this serious you know seriously you
know you're wasting my time all these
students those teachers got to go so I
mean that's a little bit of an edge
performace you but it works in every
sector you know it does you're right
yeah well we took a Thanksgiving segment
and turned it into something about how
more people should be fired